People were really upset and men were really upset.
Like it's literally the closest thing I've ever heard of.
Audio pornography heard a lot of men rap.
It's aimed at young American girls. Can you even imagine what it's doing to that
clean, wet P word, people are like, this is vulgar inappropriate.
What about the children that look up to them?
Do women achieve equality by aspiring to and replicating the
values that have been established by male? Try our best to enjoy it.
But it's been a lot of politics that a female rabbit that'd be bad golf.
And Tommy talking about the dolphin us got not the one
that horny.
My name is Brandy blaze.
I primarily do a lot of trap music rooted in feminism.
It's really important for me as a fat black woman.
That's Joey natto.
Again, most of my following from YouTube, I make positive.
Motivational music, hard to see through the lies. No, I don't get the picture.
I'm black Muslim and I care about activism.
My name is pinky ring [inaudible].
I am an MEC and hip hop cultural ambassador for the United States.
I am queen Herbie.
The messages in my music are definitely centered around self care and building
confidence and knowing your worth on the CNCS. If you lose such a pleasure.
My name is Ruslana.
I'm a Christian and the vision for what I do is to encourage, empower,
inspire people to live God's dream for their life.
My name is Mike Savage. I represent weird kids like myself,
who didn't necessarily fit in, in school and stuff.
And the first prompt is wrap should only send uplifting and
meaningful messages. Brandy, I'm going to disagree,
Joey.
I think I'll say strongly disagree. I actually disagree too.
Pinky, strongly disagree queen.
I disagree or son agree. Some-odd.
Strongly disagree as, as a father,
as someone who has kids as someone who has little nieces and sees the
consequences of there not being enough uplifting and meaningful music,
I think it should. I think there should be substantially more.
I don't think that lyrics have to be uplifting and
meaningful. I feel like, you know,
like the police that wasn't uplifting to some, but it was uplifting to others.
Shouldn't only be an always be because ain't sweet all the time, right?
Particularly.
In communities of color is not right. And we need to talk about that.
We need to report on that.
I've heard someone like in being a rapper as the weather man or weather woman,
um, where you just tell it how it is outside.
I think that we put undue pressure
on rappers to be role models for young people.
We're never really telling these rock stars who were out here doing Coke and
like having sex with all these women that they need to be a role model for their
community. So why are we always putting this heavy, heavy pressure on rappers?
And I said, strongly disagree,
but like really like stuck out to me a lot because I hate when female
artists are like oversexualizing themselves.
And I think my same reaction happened with Nicki Minaj and Cardi B. I was like,
they're doing too much like oversexualizing themselves.
Like I do not like them now, but you know that they're not there to,
you know, be all rainbows and butterflies.
So I think that was just a great point and it really, you know,
shifts my perspective.
My thing is when the,
the culture as a whole start shifting and going darker and darker and
darker, and this is what I mean.
Can we all agree that illicit drug use is bad popping pills, heart.
We're not talking about smoking week. What can we all just say? Yeah,
no good big bet. Drugs bad. Right? Well,
you have one of the biggest pop stars. Who's a,
who's a grown man in his mid thirties and a father and the chorus of
his song is him about talking about popping pills. I take a half,
she took the whole thing and we, we, we,
we take that and it just goes over our heads and we're just so numb to it.
We're so desensitized to it. Look, Drake is not my son's role model.
He will never be my son's role model. I, my son's role model, I'm the father,
but let's be honest. There are kids there, a lot of them,
black and Brown kids from poor areas where single parents are prevalent,
single parent homes are prevalent. You think that these, these,
these icons don't have massive influence on them. So you guys are right. Yeah.
I don't expect Drake to be a role model,
but I expect that 34 year old dad to be mindful of who's listening.
I have been listening to Eminem and I mean,
old school Eminem who did not give a about anything,
seeing whatever he wanted since I was a baby, as I was born,
I don't know if it was playing in a hospital room as I was coming out as all
I've been listening to. And I'm still who I am today.
And the reason being is because my mom has always allowed me to watch and listen
to these things and has always pulled me to the side and said,
Eminem could rap about killing people and popping pills,
but that's not real life. That's not what you're going to do.
You were really blessed. Your mom is a real one. Yeah, thank God. You know,
my mom at the same time that she told me these things, every once in a while,
my father wasn't around.
So she was in and out of the house working and going to college.
She wasn't really around like that either. Uh, I did get into some,
some things that I wasn't supposed to get into. I had older cousins,
older siblings who were affiliated with gangs, uh,
family members who were drug dealers and stuff like that. Like I may.
Have grew up in a decent neighborhood,
but every single person in my family was not in the neighborhood that I was in.
Growing up. I had a really incredible single mom,
but my mom didn't censor any music I listened to.
I ended up listening to a lot of Missy Elliot.
A lot of little Kim little Kim is my icon.
So I grew up with a lot of those messages.
And I think sometimes people just boil it down to, Oh my God,
they're influenced the kids to have sex. This is bad.
One of the messages that I got out of listening to little Kim intimacy, Elliot,
that I kept with me as an adult.
And I still keep with me is things that they don't teach them when sex ed
or your parents,
probably not going to teach you when they teach you about the birds and the
bees.
Like one thing that I learned from media that I wasn't protected from was that
you have just as much ownership as insects that you are just, Oh,
just as much pleasure. And they're supposed to deliver it to you.
That really kept me from having sex. Cause I was like,
this little rusty boys was coming around, talking about again, you know,
come to my house after school, you know, what's up. Then I was like,
Oh no. Cause Kim said, Aw.
I am happy with the state of our industry today. Brandy disagree,
Joey, I'm going to say somewhat agree. Neelum. I strongly disagree. Pinky.
I somewhat disagree queen. I disagree Russa.
Uh, strongly disagree, disagree.
I teach a hip hop program and an entrepreneurship program to my students.
And I'm still having to tell them, you need to have another hustle, right?
I want people to be able to function within the music industry and make enough
money. I'm not a hundred percent an artist yet. And that's really frustrating.
We approached this entire thing as small business owners. And we said, Hey,
I know that the first year of the business, the second year, the third year,
listen, I'm just trying to survive. But I mean, Tik TOK right now,
it could happen within a week or two where you can legitimately build an,
a new audience on sick talk that you could transition over.
You know,
you built this whole thing yourself and got to a point where it's like actually
making money,
which nowadays like you have to be huge on Tik TOK or they have to see
opportunity to get, to pull that money out of you right away.
2% of those artists actually recouped,
which means only 2% get to make a second album. Once you get in the machine,
it's like your chances of surviving. It are very slim.
I'm biased because I wouldn't have been able to flourish in a different time in
the music industry because my come up was on, um, primarily from YouTube.
I live in Boston and I'm from Boston.
If you just Google the press coverage on Boston, hip hop,
you'll primarily see women and you'll primarily see non binary artists.
And that's really something that I hope can be replicated within the bigger
industry. Like I think we're making strides towards that. We also have, um,
supportive foundations.
I received like a five figure grant to completely fund my third album.
And before that I've been a hundred percent self-funded I still have a day job.
Y'all okay. I was at work this morning.
There's a specific kind of men that run this,
that armed black men that are putting out these negative stereotypes.
No offense to anybody.
If we're talking about the negative portrayal of any race and whatnot,
we have to talk about who owns these labels, who's funding,
these labels and funding the industry. And that's what made me say,
I don't really care if I'm in an industry or not,
as long as I'm getting my back to support my family.
So that's why I strongly disagree because the music industry to me is
it's a joke. And it's the agenda.
The song wop is a feminist Anthem strongly. Yeah.
I feel like I'm going to be shifted, but for now just say disagree.
Strongly disagree. I somewhat agree. I agree.
Strongly disagree with the caveat that I actually have never heard the song
somewhat agree.
As a woman. If you're going to reduce me down to a wop,
it's a part of me. But for that to be the Anthem of, Oh,
this is what just brings us liberation as women.
That's a little joke to me.
And it also is kind of offensive because you're downplaying
me to a physical thing and I am a being that is just way too much for you
period.
Females that made that song. As far as I know.
I don't know if anybody else wrote it cause it's the music history.
Well, what's interesting about that is actually there are,
there are male writers in that song,
which is very funny because we call that our liberation, but men are telling us,
I want to gag. I want to choke.
Is this song the only Anthem for feminism? No,
not at all.
There are songs that go way beyond and talk about the actual powers that women
have beyond physical appearance and physical parts. Um,
but I know that some women find empowerment in their sexuality
and if it brings power to those women that listen to it,
then it's supporting feminism.
I definitely a hundred percent agree with that. Like I love law.
I did a remix to walk. I let us on. I don't care. But, um,
I don't the only person that said strongly agree because it is about ownership
of body and ownership of sexuality.
Sometimes I feel like when you are a rapper that does that,
either people assume that it was put onto you by men, which it wasn't,
or they assume that you can't do anything else or you're not as smart or you're
not as good. And for me personally,
sex being such a predominant theme of my music is very personal for me.
For two reasons. One being a plus sized, black women,
not only representation I've seen in myself and media is the sassy,
a sexual best friend. That's never the love interest.
That's never viewed in a sexual way. My music and watch it's.
It's just kind of like me exploring my sexuality and having that ownership.
I'm also a rape survivor.
And one way that I to cope with that was ownership of my sexuality and
ownership of my body because I was taken away from me.
And obviously that's not the way that a lot of people are going to cope,
but for me, that was how I coped. And I got through that trauma.
That's as intense as getting those things ripped away from you is that it's mine
now.
And I have a hundred percent ownership of it and how I choose to display it is a
hundred percent on me.
And I feel a lot of power and a lot of liberation from that.
And I think it's okay if you don't,
but I don't think you should just count women not to.
And facts on facts on facts. Um,
I just wanted to say so I somewhat agreed. Um,
because there are other songs that I would say are probably better feminist
anthems, right? But when we think about what feminism is, period,
it's just believing the equality of both genders, right?
So if we can have dudes talking about their and seeing,
and sucking and all of this stuff,
then like people were really upset and men were really upset at
why they went honey. They were mad, mad, mad, mad, mad.
Why can't I show my young girls that owning their sexuality is powerful then.
Right? Like I wish someone told me that. And um,
I Brandi,
thank you so much for sharing that because I share the same experience. Um,
why can't we have someone
telling us that so that we know to own it before someone else is taking that
from us?
For me, the wop song is, is another. I also covered it for me.
It was like a huge liberating moment.
And this is coming from an artist that has a song called BDE,
which stands for big Dick energy.
Because this whole time I've been trying to liberate myself sexually and like be
comfortable with who I am and what my desires are. As a woman,
I thought I needed to put on a fake Dick, you know,
and write a song about like that. My energy has a big dig.
It was just so liberating for me to hear women. And by the way,
shout out to mega stallion who is a prolific freestyler.
I'm pretty sure she probably wrote her bars. I just wanted to add that my,
my little lens of perspective from a little Nebraska.
For the first time, it feels like in a long time, it's,
she's talking about what she wants to do and what she likes instead of talking
about what a man likes into what a man wants and stuff like that.
And that's why I feel like the power comes from.
I also think that men were upset because of the sample.
So the original song that has, there's some holes in that house. That's great.
It's a classic. Everybody knows it, but a woman took it and flipped it.
And now it's not about degregation anymore. It's about liberation.
Then now it's a problem.
As expected. This conversation did really shift my view on the wipe.
I've only heard it once because once was enough for me because it didn't make me
mad, but it was just too much.
Like it's literally the closest thing I've ever heard. The audio pornography,
you know, I was bounced into it and everything like everybody's flow.
Like I could appreciate.
The artistic nature.
You must not have heard a lot of men rep because that's.
What do you see?
Yeah, no, I guess maybe because it's the shock value and I'm wondering,
what do you think the intent was behind the song?
Do you think it was to like empower women or do you think it was to shock people
and get views and clicks? Just from the shock factor?
A lot worse comes from men. So I was like,
y'all are y'all are scandalized by this
I a hundred percent agree with you brand new. It was like, Oh my God.
It was like, first of all, too, it's consistent with what car do you do?
Why are you guys so like, Oh my God, like you haven't heard her. That's crazy.
Cardi was being Carney.
Is this notion that men were upset. Like I wasn't upset. I saw the promo for it.
And I was just kinda like, I've seen this story before.
This is little cam pass for me in this being an Anthem for feminism.
Uh, what, uh,
what other modern songs are better representation or what are modern feminist
anthems that don't degrade?
I believe it was rolling stone,
like declared Rhapsody's last album Eve as like, uh, the,
a masterpiece in hip hop feminism or something like that. The fact that,
you know,
some people don't know that about her or don't know that about her album or
having listened to her album means that as women we're losing the fact that wop
comes out and now we're celebrating our sexuality and men are up in arms and
upset about it, but don't check their own when it comes to that. We're losing.
As long as we continue to function within a patriarchal society and a genre of
music that is inherently misogynistic, we're losing,
I have felt discriminated against in my industry.
I strongly agree. Somewhat agree. I agree.
Strongly agree, somewhat agree, somewhat agree.
I agree.
So I've had a lot of doors shut just based on the way that I look,
no one even cared. If I could rap, it was automatically,
you're a woman. And then if people could get over that,
they couldn't get over my size and being a plus size woman that wraps a
lot about a lot of sexual things. I got a lot of notes just based on that.
Like no one wants to hear that from a woman that looks like you.
So not necessarily that they don't want to hear it from a woman at all.
It was very much a woman that looks like you.
But I also get a lot of love from people that are like, you look like me,
you look like my family.
You look like my friends and we all want to do the whole, Popolo some song.
So we want to hear it.
I'm just living for you. I just love you so much.
We know.
That representation matters, right? We see it all the time. And yet,
for some reason, when it comes to bigger women, it's just, no,
but not that kind of representation,
but there are women out there that want to hear that,
that want to feel empowered in their bodies and their sexuality.
So my friends are rapper rappers, right?
And so they are constantly like pink.
I don't understand what the problem is. And I'm like,
it's because I have a vagina. That's really all it is.
Gender. I think in like hip hop,
especially is the most common description.
There's a prototype of a female rapper. And if you don't fit it naturally,
you're getting discriminated against.
I'm kind of like a full pot in this industry. Cause it's like,
not only are you not hypersexualized, you're fricking Muslim. So it's like,
dude, you don't even fit in this category. You know what I'm saying?
Back in the day,
I used to be able to listen to little Kim and Lauren Hill on the radio, both,
you know? And I just feel like there's just a need of balance.
Yeah. And even when you do have your Cardi and you have someone like a Rhapsody,
why isn't she getting as much funding or as much airtime and as much play
because she is the opposite. She is something that we need and want. So,
um, I teach, uh, hip hop, mostly young women.
And a lot of them didn't even know who she was.
Didn't know a lot of these sort of underground women MCs that are doing really
dope stuff. And it's like, why aren't we putting money towards that?
I have to still put myself in agree because of the content that I choose to rap
about. I rap about real things that are going on in the world.
I rap about how there they're more than 75,000 black women missing in the world
ever have about the thing that's going on in China,
Israel and Palestine. I write about all of that stuff.
So a lot of people are afraid to get on tracks with me because they think that I
might get blackballed in that might get them black bolt. So it's by choice.
I love this discrimination.
Wow. I'm so happy that I'm a part of this conversation.
You guys already pointed out so many lenses that I don't even see.
And I think definitely as a white woman making black music,
I think it's important to acknowledge that.
Do you feel like you've been discriminated against for being a white woman in
rep?
The first deal that I signed was with LA Reid and one of the first things he
said after the ink was dry, was like, we're not going to rap. Like you are,
you're gonna fit into this like Katy Perry box much better.
Like if you want to get the bag, this is what you do. And you know,
when LA Reed tells you that, that's what you, you listen for the longest time,
I had to sort of unpack what that meant and what my lesson was leading me to.
And I had to be honest,
a lot of work to do in terms of learning the art form of
rap.
Just personally,
a motto that I do my best to live by is I go where I'm celebrated and not
just tolerated. Like I'm an, I'm an immigrant refugee.
English is not my first language, but I'm viewed white by society.
So I have a degree of white privilege. I'm a white guy in hip hop.
Who's an independent artist, who's a Christian.
So it's just like all those different things.
There's a degree of discrimination that I faced because of all
that. But I would say it,
the privilege that I've had of being viewed as a white male in society has far
outweighed the, any consequences or any negative sides of,
you know, being the minority in a black art form.
Music can lead to real life.
Violence against women disagree. I agree. I agree.
Strongly agree. Somewhat disagree.
I agree. Somewhat agree.
If I'm saying everyday hope, slip, trip, hope slip trick.
And I'm listening to that over and over again as a woman to
constantly hear that. And as a man or a young boy to constantly hear,
that's how you talk to talk about a woman and then your perception that you have
on women and you see a girl and you're like, Oh,
it's only because I hear that over and over again. She's, she's a whole,
she's a. You know what I'm saying?
And then even changes how I treat her now I treat her like, she just nothing,
you know what I'm saying? Cause I constantly had that in my ear.
I just think it would be foolish to think that incantations and grill and that
those songs have that type of power. When we think about violence,
like it doesn't have to mean physical violence all the time.
Right. Um, I feel personally traumatized sometimes when I hear some,
some music or certain things that are said,
I think it was Rick Ross that had like a line that was about like, you know,
raping a woman or, you know what I mean? That traumatized me.
So when we think about violence,
like we have to understand that it's not just actual physical harm that's
happening. It could be mental, emotional.
She made me like kind of think of kind of like that spiritual or like emotional
violence, which I really didn't think of.
So I'm not going to say change with disagree.
I'm going to say somewhat disagree because I still do. Um,
just that violence against women mindless in general is the
beginning of time.
A lot of the biggest influences are right in our neighborhoods right on our
block. You know what I mean? Like if I know my father got killed on a block,
then yeah.
I'm much more likely to have a gun and much more likely to probably go kill
somebody else. I don't think that has anything to do with gangsters.
I agree with you. I feel like it, you can't blame violence on music,
but I like I'm like in South central and stuff like that, I just know like,
as far as the suggestion is a suggestion just in the
psyche.
A lot of this stuff is theme music.
I've been on rides where people were saying really snitching on myself.
I've been on rides where people were like have evil intent and whatnot.
And they were on their way to go do some evil stuff. And what were they playing?
What were the theme songs? You, you guessed it some gangster rep.
So can it influence and encourage? Yes,
but it's not the blame. Um, I listened to shoot them up,
rap music. Whenever I listened to that,
while I'm cleaning the dishes in my suburban home and it
doesn't make me say, you know what,
let me stop doing these dishes and go run outside and kill somebody.
Great.
I just want to say I'm grateful for all these perspectives because I chose
somewhat disagree because I don't want it to be true.
I don't want to think that music can influence violence in that way.
So I just am grateful because I am how.
My brain actually processes that I'm thinking about the next generation.
I'm thinking about my nieces.
I'm thinking about my nephews that aren't there yet where they don't understand.
Yeah.
I consume this song for escapism and I consume this song to be in touch with my
inner freak. I think there's a balance there,
but I definitely think that if you're not in the right frame of mind,
you can definitely be triggered to go do some wild stuff by a song or the song
is just playing. And if you're mentally weak,
then you're going to be influenced your eat.
You're more prone to be influenced by music to do, you know,
carry out violence and stuff like that.
But also remember drive-bys did definitely happen in the seventies when
everybody was listening to funk music. So anything can happen to anything.
I'm going to be thinking about a lot of things.
I feel like I'm just going to be looking at a wall,
thinking about life for the next three hours after this whole conversation.
And you guys were all really fun to talk to and listen to.
You can learn something from everyone.
And I really loved it and I wish the industry can be as diverse as
this all y'all span. Now that's just, it. That's all I have to say. Period dot.
Let's give women MCs their flowers now, please.
Right. Let's support them.
Let's uplift them because how are we going to get to the next phase?
Unless like we all said, we are the ones that we have to support.
Like the more we're going to start seeing this resurgence of other young women
who come up and are able to do it because we are paving the way for.
Hey guys, thanks so much for checking out this episode.
The music we consume directly influences how we participate in a culture that
accepts the oppression and violence against women and girls.
Spotlight initiative and the social good club have teamed up on a mission to
help all types of content creators across the world to use their platforms,
to help shape a culture without male dominance,
to create safe spaces for everyone to live in peace and thrive.
They have rolled out a playbook to kickstart this journey.
So make sure to check it out@socialclub.com.
Be sure to follow them at spotlight initiative and at the social good club and
check out the hashtag with her. Thanks for watching.
And we'll see you next time.